well I have to admit as a consumer a
normal consumer I prefer a strong euro
to a weak one but that is of course a
very subjective view and not necessarily
one that's economically sound for the
country as a whole but for an
economically sound analysis we have an
expert here with us and kudelka from the
University of duisburg-essen welcome on
the show go to have you with us so
please tell us when does a robust euro
pose a threat for Europe if the u.s. is
too too strong in a sense then it might
be the case that inflation is going down
because imported goods become more cheap
and this is exactly what we do not want
to see right now in the your area
because some speak of deflationary
tendencies in the south at least of the
your area okay there you mention already
something about problems especially in
the south because the eurozone and the
common currency the single currency
certainly has revealed that this
scenario can pose problems among various
eurozone member states and they're very
very different economies there is a
survey that makes it very clear because
it shows that a common Europe exchange
rate we should see it right now it is
very tricky Germany for one can handle a
stronger euro exactly of 1.5 to against
the US dollar France would be okay with
1.23 the best exchange rate for Greece
would be 1 euro 02 against the dollar so
quite different there how can the ECB
make everyone happy so it cannot do so
of course it has to orient its monetary
policy at the average of the euro area
and concerning its tattooed it's even
forbidden to look at the exchange rate
as a center target so you have some
program countries or former program
countries like Ireland now Portugal
which have put in much endeavor into
becoming more competitive right now and
maybe they are punished by a too strong
exchange rate but Germany's experts
depend very much on quality of its
experts who can afford a high exchange
rate getting punished me
monetary policies actually solve that
that huge difference between the various
member states and can be easy be at the
same time stay an independent body as a
stylist fact monetary policy can never
solve structural problems even reform
effort goes down if you are to spend
inary so it cannot be a standard you
have to look at political independence
of the central bank of course the
central bank has become politically
dependent as we have seen in the past
because the ECB was a member of the
so-called troika and the program
countries and now look at France France
mrs. it's the deficit target quite
clearly they want the ECB to activity
directed state because they're ashamed
of their bed export competitiveness
performance well mr. Beckert we've got
the EU parliamentary elections coming up
and there are some parties that suggests
that there should be a kind of to class
euro zone one for the week south and one
for the strong north at least temporary
would that be a solution I don't think
that this can work because if you
segment the you area and have some weak
group of we countries they would be
punished with a flexible exchange rate
and this is just a mallow so if you exit
such kind of common building like the
euro area and they have to increase
interest rates even further to keep
their currency strong okay okay okay
thank you very much for filling us in